well giddy up the National Finals Rodeo
kicks off today there's so much to see
so much to do inside and outside of the
Thomas and Mack and that's where Candace
Charles is saddling up this morning for
what she's promising to be a wild ride
put it on cowgirl let's see it
[Music]
good morning folks I do have to say it
it is a wild ride if you're coming on
down here for the Wranglers National
Finals Rodeo here in lots of Vegas
there's just so much to see and do as
Sherry mentioned and you know what you
can become a real cow cow like I did I
got a little trick I gotta show you
because the last show me this over here
is Jake
that used to be one of my boyfriend's
names so it's kind of perfect that this
horse's name is Jake and the last show
me a quick trick really quickly
it's closed
I go down
and enjoyed but there's a fire general
manager Alan ridenberg thank you so much
for joining me today you guys have so
much going on in the next 10 days tell
us all about it well it's great to be
back in Vegas this town really turns
into a cowboy town when we come and
there's so much to do The Fan Experience
here at the Thomas and Mack is
unbelievable we have the prcasm when you
arrive we have the front uh Plaza that's
all with vendors and shopping
experienced food you can go into the
Cowboy Corral listen to music ahead of
time and then the rodeo starts at 5 45
and we're ready to kick it off and these
competitors are ready to go and we're
excited about these next 10 days yeah so
something's going to be an amazing time
hundreds of thousand people are going to
be descending on Las Vegas a lot of them
going to Cowboy Christmas was kicks off
also today at 9 00 a.m but I gotta ask
because I hear the purse is huge 10.5
million dollars for the winners right so
what is the tip to win it how do you get
that first well you got to be on your
game like I said earlier you got to be
on your game when you come here uh
there's 15 the top competitors in each
event and they're all vying for the same
amount of money so they're they're
really uh working hard and hunkering
down right now and this is a time that
uh been to Peak and you know they've
been working all year to get here and
it's exciting to watch this unplay this
year this week nice nice out okay now I
know you said you got to work hard and
I've been working hard so this show me
exactly how to get on a horse here I
think I got it get up the steps right
okay
[Music]
yes okay
[Music]
you guys are gonna see this coming up oh
see my friend Jake of course you know I
always live of course I got to cover all
the details on their website newsnow.com
again it all kicks off today at Thompson
Max today at 5 45 Cowboy Christmas at
the Las Vegas Convention Center at 9 00
a.m again you guys forgot to cover with
the details go to our website
newsnow.com and come on back to see me
hop on Jake here I think Jake is uh half
asleep you should be okay yeah Jake Jake
get moving Jake's just chilling Jake's
like when is this reporter gonna do this
I know come on lady get on get on